sino hacer sonar la alarma
y abogar por el cambio.
Con razón o no,
nuestra posición social nos da a nuestras voces gran credibilidad,
y no debemos desperdiciar eso.
Me arrepiento de no hablar en Zimbabue,
y me he prometido a mí misma
que como comisionada de salud de Nueva York,
voy a utilizar todas las oportunidades que tenga
para hacer sonar la alarma
y conseguir apoyo para la equidad en salud.
Voy a hablar en contra del racismo,
y espero que se unan a mí,
y me les uniré cuando levanten la voz contra el sexismo
o cualquier otra forma de desigualdad.
Es hora de que nos levantemos
y hablemos colectivamente
acerca de la desigualdad estructural.
No tienen que tener todas las respuestas
para exigir cambios.
Solo necesitamos coraje.
La salud de nuestros pacientes,
la salud de todos nosotros, depende de ello.
(Aplausos)